i try to be completely
unanimous uh now in my all public
interactions i try to be as real in
every way possible like zero gap between
private
me and public me why exactly did you
it seems like this is an intentional
mission what made you want to
sort of bridge that gap between the
private sphere and public sphere
because that's that's unique i know a
lot of intellectuals who would
make a different decision yeah
interesting i had a
discussion about with naval about this
actually with a few others
that have a very clear distinction
between public and private
something i'm struggling with by the way
personally i'm thinking about
so one on the very basic surface level
is uh
if you carry with yourself lies
small lies or big lies it's extra mental
effort
to remember what you uh
like to remember what you're supposed to
say not supposed to say
so that's on a very surface level of
like
it's just easier to live life when
you're have the smaller the gap between
the private you and the public you
and the second is
i think for me from an engineering
perspective
like if i'm dishonest with others
i will too quickly become dishonest with
myself
and in so doing i will not truly be able
to think deeply about the world and come
up and build revolutionary ideas
there's something about honesty that
feels like it's that first principles
thinking that's almost like overused as
a term but
it feels like that requires radical
honesty not radical assholesh
but radical honesty with yourself with
yourself
and i feels like it's difficult to be
radically honest with yourself
when you're being dishonest with the
public and also i have a nice feature
honestly that um in this current social
context so we can talk about race and
gender
and uh what what are the other topics
that are
touchy ethnicity and um nationality
all those things i mean like family
structure i
maybe i'm ineloquent in the way i speak
about them but
i honestly when i look in the mirror
like i'm not
deeply hateful of a particular race or
even just hateful particular ace
um i'm sure i'm biased and i tried to
like think about those biases and so on
and also i don't have any creepy in
my closet
i haven't done it seems like everybody
uh
it seems like a lot of people got like
did a lot of creepy stuff in their life
and i i just feel like that's uh really
nice
and deliberating and especially now you
know it's funny because i've gotten a
bit of a platform
and uh i think it all started when i
went this is the fame
miss comedian female comedian whitney
cummings and
you know i've gotten a lot of amazing
women writing me
throughout but when when i went on
whitney
it was like the number of dms i get on
instagram
for women is just ridiculous and uh
i think that was a really important
moment for me is like
i speak and i feel you know i really
value love
long-term monogamy with like one person
and it's like i could see where a lot of
guys
would now continue that message in
public
and in private just start sleeping
around and so like that's an important
statement for me mentally he's like nope
it's very narrow just go straight and
not out of fear but out of like
principle and just like
live life honestly i just i feel like
that's
truly liberating uh as a human being
forget public
all that because then i feel like i'm on
sturdy ground
when i say uh difficult things
and at the same time sorry i'm ranting
on this i apologize i'm interested
personally so keep going
i i honestly believe in the internet
in people on the internet that when they
hear me speak
they can see if i'm full of or not
like
i won't be able to fake it you know like
they'll
see it through uh yeah i
so like i feel like if you're not lying
about stuff
you have the freedom to truly be
yourself and the and the internet
will figure it out like we'll figure who
you are people
have a natural tendency to be able to
tell and it makes sense from an
evolutionary standpoint right exactly
like why why wouldn't why like
of all the things that we could evolve
to be good at
being able to detect honesty seems like
one that would be particularly valuable
especially in the sorts of societies we
developed into and then also from a
selfish perspective like a success
perspective
i think there's a lot of folks that have
inspired me uh
like the elon is one of them that
shows that there's a hunger for
genuineness
like you can build a business as a ceo
and be genuine and like real and do
stupid every once in a while
as long as it's coming from the same
place of who you truly are
like elon's inspiration with that and
then there's a lot of other people i
admire
that are counter inspirations in the
sense like they're very
formal they hold back
a lot of themselves and it's like i know
how brilliant those people are
and i think they're not being as
effective of leaders
public faces of companies as they could
be
i mean to be honest like not to throw
shade
but i will it's like mark zuckerberg is
an example of that
uh jack dorsey's also a bit of an
example that i like jack a lot i've
talked to him a lot
i will talk to him more i think he's a
much more amazing
person than he conveys through
his public presentation i think a lot of
that has to do with pr
and marketing people having an effect
this is difficult i think it's really
difficult it's probably
many of the same difficulties you will
face is the pressures
but it's it's hard to know what to do
but i think as much as possible as an
individual you should try to be honest
in the face of the world
and the company that wants you to be
more polished
and that being more polished turns into
a politician
and politician eventually turns into
being dishonest
dishonest with the world and dishonest
with yourself
you